بمراره هنا قضاء ايضا في طوارئ المشفى وهو
يحاول التغلب على وباء حمى الضنك لكنه بدى
اليوم محظوظ عن غيره صيام الذين ساءت
حالتهم فتوجب على الاطباء وضعهم تحت
الرعايه الصحيه المركزه في هذه الغرف
المغلقه
بسرعه
اعداد المصابين بالحميه في تعز الى اكثر
من احد عشر الف حاله في هذا العام
فقدوا حياتهم نتيجه الوباء
50 الى 70 حاله يوميا من الحميات كانت
الملاريا جميع انواع الحميات تاتيلها
مستشفى
[موسيقى]
في مدينه تعز اكثر من 11,000 حاله منذ
بدايه العام حتى اليوم
ينظم هذه الحالات طبعا سجلت خلال الشهر
الثلاثه همم ست اغسطس وسيبتمبر واكتوبر
وايضا هناك 15 حاله وفاه
اتساع رقعه انتشار الوباء في المدينه هذه
طاقم من معاناه السكان بلوجع على المدينه
تعيش في كارثه صحيه مع انعدام الادويه
وافتقار المستشفيات لابسط المستلزمات
الطبيه في ظل حصار الميليشيات المطبق على
المدينه منذ سنين وما ترد الوضع الصحي في
المدينه تزداد اذا نسبه الاصابه بالحميات
سيما حمى الضنك الذي اثقل كاهل المواطنين
في هذه المدينه فالمستشفيات هذه تستقبل
العشرات يوميا من هذه الحاله ال سعيد
العربيه تعز